how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and the MCU was supposed to be
moving full force right now the Black
Widow movie was supposed to be out in
April / May the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series along with the Wanda
vision series would have been done
filming and we would have gotten
trailers for both of them already and
the Eternals would be right around the
corner and we would have probably gotten
a trailer for them already as well but
unfortunately due to Kovan 19 Marvel's
phase 4 was pushed back and not just
Marvel but pretty much every studio as
well but pretty much everything got put
on hold for Marvel all of their current
projects were delayed and it's been a
while since we've really gotten anything
new from Marvel Studios or Disney
directly and unfortunately it looks like
phase 4 is going to be delayed again and
that truly is a bummer but the good news
is that doesn't necessarily mean that we
aren't getting new material soon and
I'll talk about all of that in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU as it's
changing a lot day-by-day and also so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a Doctor Doom Funko pop
all you got to do to enter subscribe to
my channel like the video and leave a
comment about the video down below so
for a while things we're looking pretty
good for Marvel Studios and for theaters
reopening but unfortunately kovat 19
isn't exactly under control right now
and there have been many different
reports from many different sources that
say theaters most likely will not be
opening back up in July like they said
they were the three biggest theater
chains in North America said that by the
end of July they all should be open and
this was great news at the time but it
doesn't seem like that's going to happen
anymore and this is very big news for
phase 4 of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
because as you know things go in order
for the MCU everything is connected and
according to the reports that we've
heard about movie theaters closing it
says that they probably won't open up
until mid next year of 2021 which means
that Black Widow
if this happens will be pushed back to
at least mid next year probably the end
of next year because Marvel Studios
isn't going to want Black Widow to be
one of the fur
movies in theaters when movie theaters
first opened back up they're gonna want
them open for a while before they
release the film and Marvel and Disney
have already shown signs that they are
in fact delaying their current phase
four projects a few weeks ago Marvel
teased us with a little teaser date for
the Falcon in the Winter Soldier on
Disney Plus on Disney Plus when you
clicked on the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier for more info it said coming
December 31st year 3000 now this was
obviously a tease and it was obviously a
reference to Iron Man I Love You 3000
but a couple of weeks later Marvel and
Disney did add a full description
synopsis and a actual release date and
it said the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier following the events of Avengers
and game Sam Wilson / Falcon and Bucky
Barnes lost the Winter Soldier team-up
in a global adventure that tests their
abilities and their patience in Marvel
Studios as the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier the all-new series is directed
by Carey Skoglund Malcolm Spellman is
the head writer coming fall 2020 so that
led everybody to believe that yes the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier were going
to be released in August but sadly as of
yesterday Marvel Studios and Disney Plus
have officially removed that release
date now sometimes we think that that
might not necessarily mean anything it
still could be released in August but
unfortunately Disney Plus has come out
and revealed everything that they are
going to be releasing in August and the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier are not on
there they're releasing a few things for
Star Wars since Disney owns Star Wars
and they're releasing the original x-men
in August but no Falcon and the Winter
Soldier confirming that Marvel Studios
and Disney has indeed delayed the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier
so unfortunately phase 4 has been
delayed again and if they're going to
push back Falcon and the Winter Soldier
that means that the one division series
is most likely going to be pushed back
as well and since theaters are not going
to be reopening in July like they
planned on and not open until next year
that means the Black Widow movie is
going to be pushed back as well so the
beginning of phase four and all of phase
4 because everything is connected
there's an order that these movies and
shows have to come out in
all going to be pushed back and this is
super sad news but let's end it on some
good news we've had several reports over
the past couple of weeks that lead us to
believe that a lot of new Marvel
material is coming soon now they're not
projects being released but they are
teaser trailers and regular trailers for
a few upcoming projects we've got word
that not just one but two new trailers
for the Black Widow movie could be
coming we also got word that the teaser
trailer for Marvel's Eternals should be
coming relatively soon as well and the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier series and
the Wanda vision series
teaser trailers have been rumored as
well Marvel Studios is not attending
Comic Con at home but are believed to
still be releasing all of this material
for the fans since we haven't got
anything in a very long time it's
believed that new footage will be shown
when the NBA starts back up in a couple
of weeks since Disney owns several
sports networks and have been known to
show new footage or new trailers for
some of their Marvel shows during these
events and not to mention CC XP is
coming up pretty soon as well and
perhaps Marvel has some plans for that
so it is sad news that phase 4 is going
to be pushed back but hopefully we get
some new footage new trailers and a lot
more information about the upcoming
projects soon hopefully things turn
around and get under control and we can
see these projects that we've been
waiting for it for a very long time now
sooner than we think but let me know
which project you're looking forward to
the most in Marvel's phase 4 let me know
in the comments down below and don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on anything
relating to the MCU for live updates you
can follow me on Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf